well Maria and is editor-in-chief of EVN
report an online Weekly Magazine focused
on Armenia she joins us from the
Armenian Capital Irvine welcome to the
program so let me ask you first despite
this ceasefire what are you hearing
about what's happening on the ground in
the region
well first of all I think it's important
to say that this is an unequivocal and
clear case of ethnic cleansing entire
villages in the Grano garato have been
depopulated population centers have been
attacked women and children have died
and the argument by Baku that this is
some anti-terror operation has been
rejected by the entire International
Community and no one is really buying
this absurd argument right now there are
tens of thousands of displaced Armenians
who are Sheltering uh still in bunkers
because
their their situation is not clear
thousands more at the Russian base in
stepanage and we've been hearing from
them that the Russians are saying that
you know we don't know what's going to
happen with you at the moment and the
weaponization of the concept of
territorial Integrity is also not
working because one cannot engage in
ethnic cleansing simply because the
ethnic cleansing is taking place within
one's territory and more to the point
the Aliyah regime one of the most
despotic regimes in the world has no
credibility when it comes to these
issues violating human rights is the
sort of expertise of of that government
right now we have been talking with
people there are certain Villages that
are completely surrounded with no
Russian peacekeepers in sight uh by
azerbaijani forces there are women and
children who have not been able to
evacuate so the situation still
continues to remain very very critical
uh and very very worrisome we understand
they've been protests taking place in
the aravan but what do you make of those
protests
well listen Armenia is one of the most
uh or is the most democratic country in
Eurasia uh and part of democracy is
expressing
um as having the freedom to express uh
your discontent and certainly when uh an
authoritarian regime is trying to
ethnically cleanse uh your people uh
people uh in Armenia are extremely upset
and they are voicing those concerns
today uh because they did want Armenia
to perhaps do more but we also have to
understand that baku's intention was to
pull Armenia into a new conflict and
Yerevan has been very clear that it will
not be pulled into any military
operations there are no uh forces of the
Armenian armed forces in a nagorno
harappa basically has been under a siege
for nine months blockaded by Azerbaijan
with the collusion of Russia and the
Russian peacekeepers so what could
Armenia have done but clearly there are
several thousand people right now in the
the capital in yerevan's Republic Square
demanding uh the resignation of the
Prime Minister and if the government to
set up an interim National Committee and
and this is the process of democracy
people uh of course are very very upset
they are fearful of what the situation
can be because uh if you know or if you
don't know Azerbaijan in May and in
November of 2021 and then in September
of 2022 attacked The Sovereign territory
of Armenia taking over about 150 square
kilometers of Armenian territory there
are azerbaijani soldiers in several
regions of Armenia so you know since the
end of the 2020
this has been an ongoing situation okay
well let me ask you with that ongoing
situation then what do you see the
future being then because the two sides
are due to meet on Thursday what's the
outcome of that likely to be
it's very difficult to say at the moment
what the future can be I think this is
probably the worst case scenario the the
the most horrific nightmare uh for The
Armenian people what is taking place
right now in the world
um Azerbaijan since the end of the war
has been trying to force a Victor's
peace they have uh come forth with the
most
um
ridiculous
proposals and and every time Armenia
concedes to something they want more
concessions from Armenia and
unfortunately what we're seeing is that
Democratic Armenia now is caught in a
web of arusso azerbaijani access with
the role of turkey being very prominent
turkey has come out several times in
support of azerbaijan's actions in
nagornogarapa against Armenia and this
collaboration of coordination is really
indisputable uh we saw this as I said
with the blockade of the latching
corridors and just today Putin's own
spokesperson stated that he doesn't see
a case of ethnic planting and it speaks
clearly of the collaboration taking
place between Moscow and Baku now the
West has come out very aggressively
against this but unless there are
international mechanisms put into place
to help Evacuate the people of nagora
from 120 000 people 30 000 of whom are
children
um and and of course the elderly the
people with disabilities it is a a
tremendous humanitarian catastrophe that
is taking place right now right before
the eyes of of the world
we appreciate your time here in Al
Jazeera thank you
thank you